now in the United States alone companies
invest around 32 billion dollars each
year in social marketing the aim is to
reach precise target groups the emphasis
is on relevance tuned into social issues
and trend aware so it looks like razor
company Gillette's done everything right
in its latest commercial jeanette seems
to abandon its tradition of celebration
of motto role models this time around it
calls for men to shift their behavior
and reject patriarchal ideas and
concepts the commercial says today's men
should question their own maleness in
the wake of the v-2 movement chauvinist
macho simply no longer have a place in
society that's the implication of the
spot so far so good but there has been
some backlash from Gillette's main
target audience Jared reader from our
social media team is here to tell us all
about it so do tell us all about it
what's the backlash about your well I
guess you know Procter & Gamble who owns
Gillette are deliberately trying to be
provocative with an ad like this they on
the one hand have been praised for the
message which is men need to hold other
men accountable for bad behavior because
sexual abuse sexual assault is a problem
on the other hand you've got groups of
people who are saying
Gillette's accusing all men all of its
customers of being sexual abusers which
is probably a bit extreme but on the
other lower level people are saying it's
too politically correct on YouTube the
video has had over 2 million views and
over 200,000 dislikes lots of comments
from groups that are known as men's
rights activists blasting Gillette one
user saying the ad emasculates men
saying they're done engineering razors
now it's time to engineer society and
reprogram men Piers Morgan who's a
conservative commentator has called it
absurd PC gaffe fueling the global
assault on masculinity saying let boys
be boys threatening to take his business
elsewhere and lots of people are sort of
taking his lead I guess dozens of videos
like this of men throwing their Gillette
products in the trash
Gillette says it wants to promote what's
a healthy version of what it means to be
a man but
like I said it's deliberately being
provocative and social media is I guess
a hotbed of reactions and these
reactions are to be expected I would
think yeah I mean social campaigns can
backfire for companies it's hard to
really gauge isn't it it is
I like we've got some examples to show
you on the one hand we've got Pepsi that
was accused of being trying a bit to
work in 2017 when it tried to align
itself with the black lives matter
movement that was met with an outcry
when they released this ad starring
Kardashian sister kendall Jenner the
company was accused of making a mockery
of black lives matter and it pulled the
ad in the face of calls for a boycott a
more recent example is when Nike teamed
up with Colin Kaepernick a football
player of course he's attracted lots of
controversy since he started taking a
knee during the national anthem to
protest police brutality some people
were so angered that they started
burning their Nikes this backlash didn't
really hurt Nike in the end because
their sales went up 30%
Jared Reid from our social media desk
Jerry thank you so much